the airstrikes woke la viv just before 6
30 in the morning four cruise missiles
fired from the black sea hit an aircraft
repair facility on the edge of the city
again russian forces have shown they can
and will strike deep into ukraine
nowhere now is safe or off limits
we can smell the smoke in the air but
this is as close as we can get we're
probably
4 500 meters away
police and security are really on edge
this morning they are stopping every
single car that is heading towards
the airport complex there is a feeling
that this is the second time the
russians have been successful in
airstrikes around the v
and there is a worry
that there could be russian saboteurs
russian agents operating inside lev and
helping out moscow
people here had been expecting the
russians to attack the airport so many
weren't all that surprised when it
actually happened
we have a bomb shelter next door an old
soviet one this lady tells me so we will
work work and keep working everything
will be fine we are preparing for
victory
that's the sort of defiance that
president putin is struggling against in
moscow today he emerged from the
security of the kremlin to address a
vast crowd marking the 2014 annexation
of the crimea it is the first time he's
been seen in public since the invasion
began our guys are fighting are acting
during this military operation shoulder
to shoulder
they help each other they
support each other and when it's
necessary
each other like
a brother with their own bodies on the
battlefield
these images of russian nationalism and
seeming devotion to their president are
for a domestic audience but also
designed to show the world he is not a
leader on the run
[Applause]
putin has staked everything on this war
defeat is unthinkable for him with
chilling determination he finished his
speech by quoting the patron saint of
russia's nuclear fleet
in all his wonderful career he didn't
lose one battle he said once
so these storms
will glorify russia it happened then
and today
it's also so and this will be so forever
thank you
the mood here in ukraine couldn't be
more contrasting
even skripnick was killed when his base
was hit by russian airstrikes over the
weekend
his comrades mourn with the grim
realization that it could be them next
they are running out of space in the
city's military cemetery
the earth mounds of fresh graves are
marked by temporary crosses and the
portraits of the men who now lie beneath
the soil that they died defending
the pain of a mother's loss echoes
across this country
the feeling of pride for a fallen
soldier competes with stunned
bewilderment and anger
so much anger that has somehow come to
this
alice in sky news